it's interesting that you say movie
watchers or or film enthusiasts are much
more critical do you think cinephiles
are on this other end of the spectrum
and a lot of these are made for movie
lovers oh we love to go we love the big
seats that recline out over the popcorn
but in terms of really dissecting the
story and how the camera was placed
there's a very small few out there and
what's the difference between a movie
lover and a cell phone well I you know
it's a it's a good question what's the
difference between a movie lover and a
cinephile well I think a movie lover
maybe somebody it's interesting I think
movie lover maybe what you said which is
somebody who loves the event of going to
the movies the whole process it's them
it's not just the movie it's going to
the movies it's getting the popcorn it's
it's being social it's going it's
getting out of the house it's the whole
thing they may even love the you know
the trailers you know so funny though
it's like now I'm getting so old to the
point where like when the when the round
of seven trailers or whatever comes you
know I look at my wife and I go I'm
exhausted you know like I can go home
now like I don't even need to see the
movie I'm like already being bombed by
so much visual stimulus but I think a
movie lover loves the the film maybe
loves the film in the process of going
to to the film a cinephile may - but I
think a cinephile is more of a student
of cinema somebody who is more an
analytical thinker a critical thinker
someone who has a hit puts the film into
context of the filmmakers filmography
and had maybe seen everything that the
filmmakers made and is gonna constantly
reference and I think all filmmakers to
have the bit of the both in them you
know they have the cinephile in them
there's somebody who has seen every
Stanley Kubrick movie and is able to
tell you which is his favorite and which
is not you know this the cinephile will
tell you why Back to the Future 1 is
better than Back to the Future 2 and why
Robert Zemeckis you know did a stronger
job and that than he did and Back to the
Future through it you know like that
kind of nerd which I which I'm clearly
one you know of one of us you know a
movie lover is gonna be less
discriminating i think you know i think
i think it accounts for why you know i
was trying to explain to my wife about
the summer blockbuster that there was a
period when
you looked forward I look forward as a
kid to the summer because a certain type
of movie came out the summer which was
big expensive stupid bloated adventure
action like that was the time and place
for for those types of movies and it was
good because you you went into watching
those films or I went into watching
those things with a different cap on I
wasn't going in to be moved you know by
the towering inferno the same way I
expected to be moved by all the
President's Men or Dog Day Afternoon
but I was being given during the year a
certain I don't want to say you know
more intelligent kind of entertainment
but it certainly was more character
oriented and when the writing when it
was more realistic it was more nuanced
and complex and then you know it was
like that was your diet and then summer
was like just desert and you could just
get these and it's funny now it just
seems like it's all summer you know it's
almost like the summer isn't special
anymore because these movies are coming
out death that's what's getting made you
know during the year too so I don't know
I don't know if that answers your
question but I think the cinephile is
definitely more discriminating and has
more to say about the film and the
filmmaker so how Jeff Foxworthy used to
say you might be a redneck if you might
be a cinephile Depp yeah you might be a
cinephile if you know if you start
ranking your you know your Kubrick
movies from you know one to seven or
however many of they were you know you
might be you know that yes it's a
cinephile it's just somebody who is able
to point out the the nitty gritty
you